to find a known article you can use  citation elements like author name  article title and journal name  let's search for an article written by  martin nolte in the journal blood  published in 2019  use no punctuation tags or boolean  operators  we've entered nolte blood 2019  click search  pubmed has located the article  the relevant citation is shown in the  box at the top of the search results  if this is not the citation you're  looking for  additional results are displayed below  find an article by the author doudna in  the journal nature published in 2017  notice that pubmed has identified two  articles that match your search criteria